other videos we're starting to see
emerge from what looks like the crash
state uh make for grim viewing indeed
there's lots of smoke very intense fire
in these mountains down in the south of
china uh we've had confirmation from
china's civilian aviation administration
that there were 132 people on that
flight 123 passengers and nine crew
there's also pictures of debris
circulating on chinese social media so
this looks like a very serious crash
indeed state media here is reporting
that a rescue operation is underway but
there's no sign uh uh there's no
information sorry about any of the
casualties potential casualties um so
far so this was a china eastern airlines
plane that's one of china's three
state-owned airlines it's a very big
airline here flying from kunming to
guangzhou cities in the south it's
supposed to be around a two-hour flight
but it looks like an hour into that
flight according to flight radar 24's
tracking information
that that plane stopped responding and
that uh is over the hills of guanti a
very mountainous area so that rescue
operation is underway they uh looks like
they know where this crash site is uh
state media coming out with information
um as we're getting and we'll bring you
the latest of that this is unusual for
china it used to have a pretty bad air
safety record during the 1990s but it
turned things around uh buying lots of
new planes from boeing an airbus uh
training lots of pilots up and the last
fatal crash i had was in 2010 when 44
people died because of an overloaded
plane this looks like it is a boeing
737-800 aircraft that will go down so
there will be questions there given of
course boeing's safety record over
recent years but this is still a
developing
situation state media here bringing us
the latest various uh institutions in
china bringing us latest and as we get
that we'll bring that to you